[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today I'm going to show
you all the different ways I know to
start a fire without matches
now some of these methods are more
primitive technologies survivalist style
and others are more MacGyver style but
all of these methods are fun and while I
don't claim to be a master of all these
methods I think you're gonna learn
something new and you're definitely
gonna have a good time okay the first
method I'm gonna show you is my favorite
it is so simple and it's awesome all you
need is a cotton ball a little bit of
leftover soot or ash and cement will
grease and we're gonna make this thing
burn I'm going to unwind the cotton ball
just like that okay I'm taking a little
bit of this ash and I'm gonna sprinkle
it right down in here and roll it like a
burrito as tightly as I can I'm gonna
fold over the edges so it can't come out
the sides I'm going to take about half
the cotton ball maybe three quarters of
the cotton ball and then just tear it
off okay and then I'm going to take this
other piece of 2x4 and we're gonna shape
it just do this three or four times
until it's formed enough that it doesn't
unravel when you roll it the other
direction
now I'm gonna sandwich it between the
two two by fours I'm gonna start rolling
[Music]
to tell you see smoke see ya hold it
long boys like this it encourages the
Ember to grow then
there you go how cool is that so I've
been trying this method on and off for
the last six months and doing it with
cotton balls is pretty easy I got it on
like the third try with cotton balls
doing it with paper towels or toilet
paper
it's possible I've seen other people do
it but it's much more difficult whenever
you're trying to make a fire from an
ember you need something that's really
highly flammable that you can put that
Ember inside and it'll burst into flames
okay jute works really well and you can
unravel it and make it into a nest but
I'm a dirty cheater and I like to do it
it is ready to go you put an ember in
that and that'll burst into flames
there you go now I'm gonna show you a
method on how to accidentally start a
fire without matches now you'll notice
behind me I have all these axes I like
to polish them and preserve them with
linseed oil just this basic boiled
linseed oil that you get at most
hardware stores and if you read the back
of the label carefully it'll tell you to
never leave oil-soaked rags laying about
because they can spontaneously combust
apparently what happens is when you soak
around or a paper towel in linseed oil
and expose it to air the chemical
reaction occurs something called a
polymerization or something like that
and it gives off heat and that heat gets
more and more and more until it bursts
into flame and we're gonna see if we can
make that happen without burning our
house down alright got this whole
kitchen towel here we're gonna get this
thing
smokin polish my spear just put a hole
in the ceiling you know what this
experiment needs more linseed oil now if
you want to see me making all these
Spears and axes definitely check out our
playlist we have forging playlist and
axe restoration playlist alright guys
it's a cold windy day here we're gonna
take all these oily rags put them in
this cardboard box and sit up on the
forge and see what happens it's been two
hours 47 minutes since I put the rags in
this box and it's starting to smoke
actually look at that the smoke coming
out I'm just gonna leave that here and
we'll just see what happens
well we're just past the three-hour mark
and there's a lot of smoke coming out of
that box so you can smell burning oil so
we'll see we might have flames any
moment now
there we go guys 4 hours 25 minutes this
thing lit up like a candle
ooop starting to melt my GoPro and that
is why you have to be really careful how
you store and dispose of oily rags
there's a lot of fun ways to start fires
with batteries and hopefully I'm about
to show you something you haven't seen
before alright guys here's a classic
steel wall in a 9-volt battery just put
it like that there you go if you try
doing this with any of the other
standard type batteries they won't
ignite the steel wool unless you take
multiple batteries usually about three
or more put an end end and then they'll
light the steel wall next I'm going to
show you the fire piston the fire piston
ignites a fire by super compressing air
when you compress air suddenly and
violently it heats up to the point where
you can ignite an ember
you can see here this part slides in
there and it makes a really tight seal
in the tip of the piston is a little bit
of char cloth char cloth is just charred
cloth you take some of this stuff you
burned it up make it into charcoal the
hardest part about the fire piston is
getting the ember from here into your
tinder and getting it to a flame it's a
very very delicate Ember
[Music]
there we go
mmm now you can make these fire pistons
out of wood there's lots of videos
online on how to do that or you can buy
them this one was made by a company
called boosts cook I'm not sure how
practical of the tool this is but it
sure is a load of fun let me show you
one of my favorite ways to start a fire
now if you're in the woods in a survival
situation you find this very specific
type of tree look down into the root
system and find where I've stashed a
bottle of potassium manganate and
glycerin and you can use this to start
an amazing fire now potassium manganate
is a very harsh oxidizer you can find in
most hardware stores it's used for water
filtration systems and glycerin is a
common ingredient in homemade soaps and
shampoos and things like that
if you mix the two together you'll get
fire
now if you don't have glycerin
apparently you can use sugar too but the
results are not as good
all right guys classic flint and steel
here another great way to start a fire
with flint and steel there's a couple
things that work really well you got
cotton balls they got steel wool
and CEO the three the Juke probably
burns the best now we've got three
different types of flint and steel so
first off this is the blast match you go
and you put the steel on to the Ferro
rod like that and works absolutely great
and then you've got the kind with the
magnesium strips here
get it up into a little lie in there
there you go now I've been a lot of you
guys are wondering what happens if you
ignite the entire magnesium bar one of
the more challenging primitive fire
building techniques is the fire plough
method absolutely the bone-dry Deadwood
you can't have any green wood you can't
be wet at all so you can see I took the
pocket knife and Whittle this down to a
bit of an edge there make a little
groove to run that rub the stick up and
down so once you get a good groove going
you need to find a spot to put your jute
[Music]
[Music]
over the years I've tried this method a
half-dozen times and I've come close I
can always get smoke but getting an
ember giving a number that's worth the
darn is hard and it really is an
upper-body workout but all you need is a
pocket knife and the couple pieces of
dry wood to give it a go so definitely
give it a try it's a challenge all right
I'm gonna show you another primitive
fire-making technique the fire saw this
is one that you use with bamboo and I
just so happens and I have a 20 foot
long piece of bamboo from another video
I did get a long piece of bamboo and you
want it long so that you can go and put
your leg on then you take some of your
they're tender or jute you slide it
under there you want it to be packed up
in there so that it's touching the top
you're gonna start sawing you just we go
nice and easy just kind of groove once
you feel like you got good groove then
you start having pressure
[Applause]
[Music]
for years in making YouTube videos has
not prepared me physically for this we
can see it burned the tinder really well
almost made a amber came darn close to
igniting it but my arms are just toasted
oh the Firefly method in this just
ruined me today there's another
technique for the fire saw that's a
little bit easier for the back you take
some shorter pieces of bamboo like this
and you get a jacket or something to act
as a pad and you lean against a board a
tree trunk whatever you can then what
you do is you take your tinder you put
it right in there hold it down with your
thumbs and then start working it oops
you see I can char it and do a lot of
songs but I'm not getting a good ember
okay so this fire starting technique is
kind of cool it was used by ancient
Japanese sword smiths to start their
forged fires you take a cold piece of
steel or wrought iron and you would beat
it until it turns red hot
[Music]
oh I'm really getting a workout today it
takes a fair amount of pounding and you
really need a high-quality anvil I do
not have a high-quality anvil and I have
put this massive dent in my anvil right
there it just is horrible but there you
go that's how you start a fire with a
hammer and a piece of steel another
great method of building fire is to
harness the power of the Sun we've all
used magnifying glasses to burn leaves
and ants and that sort of thing and if
you go online there's tons of videos
about people using ice or bags of water
or even polishing the bottom of aluminum
can to focus the energy of the Sun and
build a fire
unfortunately I picked the absolute
worst time of year to do this part of
the video because it's the dead of
winter and we haven't had a sunny day in
weeks but I'm going to show you one
method that you might not have seen
that's pretty cool you unscrew the
flashlight and pull out the reflector
take a piece of the charcloth watt it up
and you're gonna put it in there then
you're gonna tilt the reflector until
the sun's rays are focused on the
charcloth go get it burning get an ember
going and then you'll dump it in to your
tinder probably the most well-known
method of starting fire without matches
is the spindle and board method I've got
this little store by spindle and Borden
kit here just to kind of demonstrate for
you and it's got this bamboo bow here
with the the rope wrapped around it
and it's even kind of ball bearings and
a little handle here and you hold this
see this is the trick when you get smoke
coming from your ash pile that's when
you know you've got it there you go all
right we're gonna try to find some wood
and do the spindle method for real for
the spindle you need something long
straight not too many knots it needs to
be bone dry and it needs to be the right
diameter I tend to like to get something
a little bit thicker than I want and
then take my knife and Whittle it down
you're looking for something that's a
softer wood like spruce or pine or even
some of the types of reeds you can use
if you're going to be doing the bow
method you can get away with about five
six inches of spindle if you're doing
the hand method you really need 18 to 24
inches of spindle all right I got a
little piece of wood in the drill we're
going to do a test piece and see if we
can get an ember we can't get a number
with the drill not could get an ember by
hand
all right so we made fire with the drill
we know it can be done all right we're
gonna take the thicker pieces and cut
them into boards now only I had an axe
aha all right there we go there's a
board all right there's a spindle looks
good
really straight gonna make another
spindle here a little bit slimmer a
little bit shorter but very straight so
I took a piece of green sapling and
strung some paracord between it for a
bow and I took this little chunk of wood
and burnt a depression into it to make a
handle and we're gonna see if we can't
do the bow and spindle method
[Laughter]
I've been at this for three hours I've
been getting tons of smoke I've burned a
lot of holes that's all I got left of my
spindle and my arms are jelly so I think
I'm gonna call it if you want to learn
how to make fire in the woods with just
a pocketknife in your bare hands
learn to do the spindle method without
the boat just using your hand put your
thumbs on the top of the spindle go like
this all the way down put lots of
downward pressure then reset your hands
and repeat you want a really long smooth
spindle
it's got not today it'll to up your
hands if it's not long enough you'll
have to reset too often I spent two
weeks in law school just doing this over
and over again with all sorts of
different types of wood to try to do
this and after two weeks while doing it
in my living room I succeeded and burned
a hole in the carpet my wife never lets
me forget that but what I learned is
that when you have the right type of
wood and the right technique in the
right conditions it happens very fast
you only have to reset about six to 12
times before you get an ember it happens
quickly if you don't have everything
just right you can do this till the Sun
sets and you will never get it so it's
all about technique and which materials
you use not brute force there's always
something new to learn and I've just
recently discovered a new method I was
done videoing almost done editing this
video and I saw something online that
was really cool there's something called
the Rope liner and it's an old-timey
liner that uses cotton rope it's
basically just a flint and steel and a
rope dispenser and you CH are a little
bit of cotton rope and then flick some
sparks onto it and it creates an ember
on the tip of this rope and you can
store it and use it to light things and
then when you're done you can go and cap
the rope snuff out the Ember and store
it in your pocket apparently it was used
in like World War one and by sailors and
anyway it was super cool and maybe I'll
go and buy one of these I just found
some on eBay
and show them to you guys in some future
videos but just wanted to throw that out
there well I hope you really enjoyed
this video I sure had a ball making it
not all of these methods are super
practical but they're all a lot of fun
so thanks for watching and don't forget
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]